beautiful sunrise out there to the east
but we've also got some sprinkles to the
north and the
west as some pop-up showers have come
very close to the valley this morning
lots of 80's
we're still pretty dry at the surface
humidity is just close to 20 percent
but we've had some energy circulating up
into lincoln county
and some of that moisture has made its
way down even close to las vegas this
morning 79 at red rock
pahrump 78 you've had some showers
around the trump valley this morning as
well
mesquite at 79 some 80 still for boulder
city
want to jump over to texas where they
had hurricane hannah hit
in south texas over the weekend bringing
some flooding rain
and some hard winds a lot of that
moisture will be feeding
into our monsoon pipeline into the
desert southwest
here's the energy up here in central
nevada we've had some pretty good
lightning
in utah over into lincoln county in the
overnight hours and then some of that
energy has found its way down into
southern nevada as far south as clark
county and southern nye county
and that's where we've seen these pop-up
showers and just some light sprinkles
reported out in summerlin
northway northwest along the beltway
some far
northwest valley neighborhoods sky
canyon providence
you may be getting a couple little
showers over into centennial hills
it hasn't been anything remarkable but
it definitely is some heavy clouds out
there dropping a little bit of rain and
you can see
over in the parum valley as well so
we'll keep an eye on that and there may
be some pop-up thunderstorms through
the early afternoon with more daytime
heating here over the next
six hours or so let's get to hurricane
douglas
it was a very very strong category four
hurricane back on friday
it has weakened considerably and thank
goodness was not a direct hit with the
hawaiian islands
but was sweeping past the island chain
just to the north
right now it's situated over kauai and
you can see the waves though that
roughed up the islands uh maui was
really looking
to maybe take a direct hit but
fortunately escaped it
there were a lot of folks that were
taking shelter and cover thank goodness
and again just escaped from being the
direct impact
of douglas it will now head out to
cooler waters and weaken considerably
106 for us today and again early clouds
maybe an isolated early afternoon
thunderstorm some southerly breezes to
about 20 miles an hour and we've got
more heat coming this week
as we finish off july we'll be up to 109
by wednesday even 110 or 11
by our last day of the month and a hot
first weekend of august everybody
heat watches have already been issued
take care of yourself